the big question now for President Trump
and the country is whether the
revelations in that FISA memo a reason
enough to end Robert Muller's Rus Russia
investigation
let's ask former FBI spokesperson John
in ireli in Minneapolis and with me here
in Washington David Rifkin an attorney
who served in both the Reagan and Bush
41 administrations David I want to start
with you should the smaller
investigation be ended with what you
know now I would not say it should be in
it but it certainly is troubling and if
further investigation reveals that there
additional misconduct that led to the
malli investigation what this memo this
memo says that the FISA warrants were
applied for with the essential element
in those warrants being the dossier they
admitted a material fact to the FISA
judge namely that the dossier was a Oppo
research document from Trump's opponent
which they did not tell the FISA Court
right but I'm curious about why you say
this is just one you know if they find
out more I mean what else could I mean I
guess they're gonna be more but isn't
that enough I mean if you are
essentially lying to a federal judge in
the in the middle of a political
campaign two weeks before an election
and doesn't that show a motivation
that's not exactly pure as the driven
snow but of course it's very troubling
it should be investigated problem well
or mauler himself or your staff are not
directly involved - I would rather focus
on what but it was started David because
the Christmas tree but look even if
there is no Mali investigation what
happened here is enormous ly troubling
it's a serious misconduct by the FBI in
the u J let's get to the bottom of it
let's prosecute the people involved I
would rather focus on the merits of a
case versus talking about at this stage
what aids implications John I think the
FBI today if I were a veteran of the FBI
I wouldn't be mad at the Trump people
are Nunez I'd be mad at the leadership
of the FBI who allowed the agency to be
politicized and frankly used in many
ways by by people who had an agenda
against this candidate Trump and then
after the election President Trump I
think the FBI agents were used and the
upper echelon and the FBI made huge huge
judgments of error at the very least I
think there's many people today inside
and outside the FBI that feel exactly
the same way first and foremost there is
no reason an investigation of this
magnitude should be run out of FBI
headquarters the Washington field office
has a thousand agents teams of people
that do this sort of thing this is a
problem of management to have let the
executive leaders allow this to occur
that's one of the things director ray
needs to address and address immediately
well I I still am trying to figure out
why director ray was saying there's a
grave concern about releasing this memo
the memo has nothing classified in it
there are no sources no methods no
compromised foreign agents names none of
that like oh that why were they putting
out including Ray
why were they putting out these false
justifications for keeping that memo
secret that to me is very concerning and
I have no reason to not like Christopher
ray I'm sure he's a wonderful person but
why are you saying it's gonna be grave
grave damage people doing the grave
damage that it to FBI or the FBI
leadership Joe answer because it looks
bad for the FBI it's pure self
protection which dovetails with the fact
that took over a year to turn this over
and required afraid of a contempt
explain explain what you're saying it
took a year for the congressional
committees to get this information from
the FBI I think a threat of contempt
it's pulling teeth is nothing to do with
classified information there's new of
the fact this is a serious misconduct
that makes FBI look bad what should
happen now serious investigation let me
just flag one thing yeah it's not just
what was in this application that timing
is very very timing application 20
election right why not do it months
earlier why not do it after elections
there's a dear Jay policy that's
reflected in the 2012 memo by Eric
Holder been there 20 general which says
you don't investigate absent exceptional
circumstances political campaigns
because if a danger would leak and
interfere with electoral process
why did
right that man was that because during
the Benghazi stuff what was that well
let's let's assume it eroded because I
believe that this was the right thing to
do but yes he was doing the 2012
elections you don't do this unless it's
absolutely essential so the real
question is not only why did you oppose
information from a court why did you do
it on October 21 2016 2 weeks before
elections what was the urgency John what
happens to the leadership of the FBI now
given what we learned today in this memo
and we're hearing that there's more to
come this is just the tip of the iceberg
as to what we're gonna learn and I can't
wait to see what it is but what should
happen John well I see it happening
already with director ray
there's movements being made somewhat
Glacier Lee but changes are happening at
headquarters you saw Mr McCabe leave
just earlier this week and in his place
is now a deputy director that's very
highly regarded throughout the
rank-and-file of the FBI you're also
starting to see other movements with
executive leaders in the FBI I think the
first thing director ray needs to do is
make sure they have wipe the slate clean
of these people that perhaps had
political agendas and are not doing what
good FBI agents are charged with doing
remaining apolitical and protecting the
Constitution of the United States and
David almost out of time but the Comey
is chief of staff former chief of staff
on TV today and he said oh well you guys
they could have gone to the to the FISA
judge and told them about the provenance
of this dossier who paid for it who
funded it there were things that they
could have done instead of releasing
this memo there's not how it works and
it's not enough to go of IG those things
have to be investigated in the public
light doing it privately is not how we
deal with serious misconduct by the
government that's not what happened with
9/11 that's not by the way what the
Senate side did with Dianne Feinstein
accusations of CIA torture etc etc it
has to be done in a public eye
gentlemen fantastic segment